ينضم الينا من جنين الدكتور مصطفى حمارشه
المدير الطبي في مستشفى جنين اهلا بك معنا
هل يمكن ان توضح لنا طبيعه
الاصابات التي وصلت الى المستشفيات الان
في جنين
وعند وصفها بان احداها خطيره ماذا يعني
ذلك
مساء الخير للجميع
وصل لدينا 8 اصابات الاصابات هي عباره عن
اصابات متوسطه بالاطراف بالاضافه الى شهيد
وصل
كان متوفي كان اصابته بالصدر اصابه خطيره
حاليا يوجد لدينا اصابه خطيره العمليات
طبيعه الاصابه
اصابه خطيره في الصدر حاليا موجوده في
غرفه العمليات وارتفع عدد الاصابات كان
سبعه الان ثمانيه
برايك من خلال يعني النظره الاولى لاي
طبيب
للمصابين الذين وصلوا الى
المستشفى هل نفهم طبيعه الاستهداف هل كان
مباشرا
يعني انا احنا نتحدث عن خبرات من خلال
الايام القليله الماضيه خلال السياحات
الاسرائيليه لمخيم جنين ومدينه جنين معظم
الاصابات التي كانت توصل الى المستشفى
يعني الهدف منها هي القتل اصابات في
الاجزاء العلويه من الجسم في الصدر والراس
والعنق
بطبيعه الحال
بطبيعه الحال الحديث ايضا عن عمليه عسكريه
قد تستمر هل لديكم معلومات من سيارات
الاسعاف المنتشره هل يمكن ان تصل الى اي
شخص
مصاب كيف طبيعه النواحي اللوجستيه بالنسبه
للسيارات الاسعاف ووصولها الى المستشفى
الوضع حاليا وضع السيد للغايه سياده
الاسعاف لا تتمكن من الوصول الى مناطق
المواجهات
يتم اطلاق الرصاص على السيارات الاسعاف
والوضع يعني يعتبر خطير جدا
اخذتم استعداداتكم فيما يتعلق بتوقع عدد
اخر من الاصابات بالنسبه للمستشفى
نعم
اذا عدت اليك بالنسبه لحاله الشهيد هل
يمكن ان يعني طبعا بطبيعه الحال
نواحي الجنائيه لا يمكن ان نتحدث عنها لكن
اريد ان افهم منك طبيعه الاصابه بالنسبه
الي لماذا كانت قاتله
اصابه الشهيد كانت في منطقه القلب يعني
منطقه الصدر الجهه اليسرى كانت مباشر على
القلب
فهو وصل وصل الى المستشفى كان متوفي
ساعود اليك في حال ورود اي معلومات جديده
فيما يتعلق بالاصابات
ونحاول ان نفهم ايضا وضع من كانت اصابته
حرجه الى اي مرحله وصلت الحاله شكرا جزيلا
لك دكتور مصطفى حمارشه مدير الطبي في
مستشفى